so check this out I am going I just was
in Austin Texas I'm now in Boston I
connected in Chicago I'm going to speak
right now I'm at a poop and shower I'm
going to speak I'm go directly to the
airport fly to London hotel shower 14
hour day sleep for four hours fly to
Lisbon Portugal shower speak leave fly
to Boston Boston New York quick drinks
meeting go to sleep wake up 5 o'clock in
next morning go back to airport go to
the Bahamas catch summit at sea give a
keynote dock in Miami land Saturday
night even for me that is some intense
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah girl I can be your everything and
you can be on a ternoon no no girl I buy
you everything yeah girl I get you
anything
let's see the culture you won't need no
money
you won't need no luggage I buy
everything you only get that you could
be new to the beach the most beautiful
feel we can sit there I'm just saying
I've been working so awesome baby you
know
yeah I was just running I got my gig
like chasse we wear
[Music]
[Music]
it's me
[Music]
yeah now we pack it the whole day and
now the doorman don't go tell just take
your clothes off at the door don't want
to mess up the deal and we just left
Margiela go hey Sami and scary how are
you I'm doing well thank you thanks for
making some time the the payment terms
are self-explanatory so I'll get it
upfront when I sign right and and then
acceptance of work is when I when I
deliver it right yep let's put that back
to January 2019 when I can do it earlier
they'll be fine with that I'm sure if we
all decide but be doing d-roc min job
it's nice and Boston today yeah me too I
like Boston I think the other thing for
you to know is that my firm vaynermedia
I continue to build to be able to bring
advertising dollars to platforms I
believe in whether I invest in them or
not and I definitely think a lot of the
candy brands and the youth brands are
gonna would find a lot of value in
advertising on that platform so I
believe monetization can happen pretty
soon and I would and I'll personally
handhold that the book life venture
capital life and now yes mark please
it's Gary Vaynerchuk
almost client life five more minutes
yo very cool okay so yeah I mean like
that's really it I'm sure you guys are
super busy but I'm very hungry to kind
of show you what we've got and really
especially I feel like our friendship
has grown so much I'm I just I'm
thrilled to have any conversation you
tell me like value prop cost structures
kpi's like let's have those
conversations I can really I just want
to basically drive it to success and
give you guys confidence to do more and
more with us so I can decide if I want
to
lose money on this one or create a
different model or or or have different
models in place and we can get into the
details of where and what and how and so
I'm very comfortable with that
conversation okay okay great thank you
so much for the opportunity to have the
combo and I'll talk to you guys soon
okay bye-bye that's how you do it do you
rock let's how you [ __ ] do it what do
you we you know when you walk in and say
we're partnering vein or even if we do
this before the announcement and we say
look we're the first person to run an ad
in the ecosystem and all the other
things that Jeff will put on from bells
and whistles it will mean something it
will put us much further along the path
of actually doing something
[Music]
hey I'm just texting this how are you oh
how are you outer nomic I said I'm
please
oh you say I really meet you how are
things good good
oh there you go we're just gonna wait
for our security team and they'll be
good to go
human nature what'd you learn about this
it's gonna be very good I think April we
start filming myself yeah we start
filming Monday well that's something I
distinctly remember the ended early
doing you were being video interviewed
at sulfide and I was like combine your
like you up stashes a little the
interview and I'm like it's time for
that you know like we have I do a lot of
time solutions work and so you know some
people who could have giant egos don't
less people who maybe necessarily you
know maybe don't need to have a giant
ego dude it's very common and so the
people who are super classy and loyal
I think build something around them
there's more meaningful over got it
SOT the Gary B's out here oh you went
video yeah see what up what up man you
twice in Nashville and in Dallas thank
you better go you're the man dude start
thanks for uh Thank You max steel top
Thank You Man I look forward to it
and answered by yourself reading for
surely such
oh man how are you doing a good bunch
awesome right second-grade teachers just
join my facebook live say hi in the
spring hey miss Briggs
how are you Carrie be dan tires vital
well great to see them to see a magic to
enjoy enjoy rock it out thank you
hello
seven
how are you ma'am to see hope you enjoy
it hey man are you doing hi how are you
ready
okay thank you you're welcome commentary
please thank you we've got a guy a blog
around if you've ever heard of them ah
he is the outspoken totally languished
media entrepreneur and bloggers filter
re v f8 inbound how are you
I'm super excited to be here on stage
tonight I thought a really interesting
thing to talk about would be
self-awareness if I could spend two to
three minutes with all of you and make
you understand that self-awareness is
probably the single most important thing
that you can spend time on for your
outcome for your future life it would be
so exciting to me if hundreds or
thousands of people left here today and
started really realizing who they
actually were what are you actually good
at are you actually in a position to be
successful what do you like doing
because the opportunities are endless
the problem is we are scared to do
different things because the fundamental
core reality is we worry about what
other people think
we worry about getting judged if we fail
one thing that I've been very blessed
with is I've traveled the world quite a
bit for business and speaking and one
thing that a lot of people may not
understand is that entrepreneurship does
not work in a lot of other countries
because failure is a scarlet letter here
in the US we're so lucky that
entrepreneurship is met with when you
fail you pick yourself back up and you
go and to me that is unbelievable and we
are blessed to be in that ecosystem and
we need to take full advantage of it
thank you
I mean you know about the shooter
my
your video on turning 50 was [ __ ]
amazing it's going to go away over time
Thank You Raj thank you so much
[Music]
rat
you
[Music]
say hey everybody at home good to see
you hit me up anytime if I could be a
help to you guys I mean that let me see
you in Boston we're gonna try to do
something in Boston specifically just to
come up and like do a dinner right just
like hang out so maybe maybe the three
of us will set it up yeah thank you very
much for saying hello
take care I really think that the d-roc
back shot is way cooler Wow then a
selfie with me I'll give you - do you
rock
[Music]
thank you so much better bailar
headin to London gotta get some sleep in
here
sleep is underrated I'm a believer tough
to come down from that hive I don't know
how you caught that scene but I know it
was a scene good day
feel good about it got a lot of work to
do though you come from that high of
performance to cleanse to actually
business calls
and so emails and some things that I
have to address so it's the reality
became pretty right got the keys love
you
just want to jump in real quick and wish
you guys are tremendous Thanksgiving
hope you're doing the football hope
you're enjoying the food but most of all
hope you take this advantage to actually
speak to your family and friends and
other things that matter right
you know I Thanksgiving a lot of people
complain they hold grudges things that
happen thirteen years ago this is the
opportunity to be the bigger man or
woman and and take the high road and
remember that you know the positivity of
things is always better than the
negativity of things and you can swallow
your pride you can be that bigger person
and you can create that next chapter of
that relationship even if it's not the
relations even if it's your great-aunt
and you don't need it to be the greatest
relationship of all time just remember
these people not going to be around in
one day and I don't know just feels like
the right thing to do
you